president Trump's in California today he
is in our state yeah
settled fees continued excitement huh
earlier today he was in San Diego and
now he's headed up to Los Angeles for a
private fundraiser and I believe we've
got some live helicopter footage of
president Trump's motorcade as it heads
towards LA we've arranged this let's go
there now let's take a look
there is the motorcade right there and
they're taking off and there's the
president and it looks like he's
stopping at a McDonald's right now
getting back on the freeway he's on his
way he's on his way up to LA and he
stopped me in a KFC now he's on his way
again and he seems to be oh no no he's
stopping at another McDonald's alright
it's gonna take a while
let's check in every now and then what's
that more we have an update we have an
update last time let's check in now
there's president Trump's limousine
again there seems to be a truck ahead of
him looks like one of those billboard
trucks it's got enough oh it's
advertising an appearance by stormy
Daniels
[Applause]
now the president's lawyer is turning
hush-money that's what's funny legs and
down
[Applause]
what's that really we have an other
update looks like prison Trump's limo
making its way it's headed up towards
the marina now it's pulling up to a
large Russian submarine president's car
is backing up I don't know why and the
Russian said Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
check it later on if we have anything
what's that what's up there's more
is that right oh I'm being told I'm
being told by a cue card not down my
being told what's that oh oh okay I'm
being told that the Trump motorcade has
made it to Los Angeles he's made it to
Los Angeles and yeah he's been blocked
by a not moving Rock by a huge group of
protesters there is no way for the
president to get past the protesters
he's not gonna make it he's not gonna be
able to get here and oh no here comes
this amazing it's Attorney General Jeff
Sessions in the General Lee
Trumpkin in the car he's made it to the
fundraiser just in time that was so
quickly
the fundraiser that's being held in a
tiny white Victorian home
you